- Moving sucks.
(upbeat music)
You know, strangers
handling your belongings,
the movers always break something.
So that's gonna be first
month and last month rent,
one month security deposit.
I'll get the paperwork started.
(music continues)
So I have finished the kitchen.
I have finished my bedroom.
I have finished the office
and I'm just wrapping up the living room.
- Okay.
So I'll get pack-a-lacking.
- I love it, I love it.
- Mind if I put on some music?
- I do not, I do not.
All right.
- I got this new dub step.
- Dub step- what is that?
I don't know what that is.
- Oh, dude.
You're gonna love it.
- Oh, cool, cool man.
(dup step plays)
I like this.
- Wait for the drop.
- I'm sorry, the drop?
(beat drops)
What is happening?
- What?
- What is this?
I can't hear you talk.
What is that?
- The music?
- I'm sorry, is that music?
- Oh yeah.
Dude, that's the dub step, man.
That's my jam.
- Well, it's a little
loud, and disorienting,
and, you know,
you're being a little
rough with my things.
- Rough with it?
Dude, your stuff is fine.
- Why am I sweating so much?
- Because you're feeling it.
- Is that a good thing?
- Yes.
Come on man, just give it another shot.
- Okay, okay, I will.
(dub step music resumes)
- Whoa, dude, you're
totally jacking my flow up.
- Dude, your nose is
bleeding and so is mine.
- Awesome.
- It doesn't really seem like music to me.
- Okay, wow, Wali
getting a little bit old.
- No, don't do that.
All right.
Come on.
No.
Didn't realize that, okay.
Yeah, what would you rather listen to?
I can hook you up with some
"Hootie and the Blowfish"
if that's your-
- Oh, that's funny.
- Is that good?
Want some "Color Me Bad?"
- You know what, go ahead.
I don't care.
I see what you're doing.
Go ahead and play it.
I don't care because I'm not that old.
I can get into it, okay.
Let's just get the stuff packed, play it.
(dup step music resumes)
Ahh!
- Ah, ah!
(car alarm blares)
- I think I'm getting it.
- Yeah!
- Oh, thank you.
- I wish I could just stay at my old place
but I can't afford the new rent.
- Yeah, moving sucks.
You know, strangers
handling your belongings,
the movers always break something.
- Oh, no, I can't afford
professional movers.
I'm moving myself this Saturday.
(suspenseful music)
(speech warps)
- I'm going to do most of the small stuff
just going back and
forth with my hatchback.
Oh, do you think you can
borrow your roommate's van,
(speech returns to normal)
so you can help me with
some of the big stuff?
- Yeah, you know what?
I've been thinking a lot lately
and I think we need to
spend some time apart.
Not to break up.
No, just some time,
time apart to figure ourselves out
and then we come back
together stronger, you know?
- This is coming outta nowhere.
- No, it's not.
I've tried to tell you like a,
like a million different ways,
but you, you don't listen, see?
That's the thing is that you never listen.
I don't need this time apart for me.
I need this time apart for us.
How long do you think it's
gonna take you to move?
- Okay, this is about the move.
You don't wanna help me move.
- What?
I would love to help you move.
That's what boyfriends do, Claire.
- I just think that
it's a weird coincidence
that you need space right
when I'm about to move.
- Oh my God.
Oh my God.
I am so sorry
that I didn't plan my emotional
turmoil around your move.
Look at your face, see?
And now you've assumed the worst of me,
because you do that.
And that's why we need to spend
time apart from each other.
- That is not fair.
- Not fair?
Babe, all I'm asking for is
12 lousy hours this Saturday.
- Okay, fine!
- Okay, fine?
- We'll move on Sunday.
- 48 hours.
I don't know what I was thinking.
12 hours is nowhere near enough time
to do what I need to do
to make our relationship stronger.
See, you got me all
confused and you know what?
I love you, but I gotta get outta here.
I can't.
I just can't.
I don't-
I'm so confused right now.
(phone dings)
I feel-
I can't think,
and the walls are closing in on me
and I just don't know what to do.
- That was my landlord.
He says he doesn't want
to lose me as a tenant
so he is not going to raise my rent.
Now I don't have to leave my place.
- And I don't need
(romantic music swells)
time and apart because
we're perfect together.
Will you marry me?
- You paint my apartment.
- Yeah, of course, I'm
painting your apartment.
That's what boyfriends do.
When exactly do you think
that's gonna happen?
- What are we doing in this neighborhood?
- Come on, this place
is in our price range.
Besides, I mean,
people say the neighborhood's
turning around.
- [Devon] Who the (beep) there?
- It's Jordan and Kira.
We're here to view the apartment at three.
- Oh (beep) my bad.
I had this homeless crack head
trying to set up house in here yesterday,
almost had to beat his ass.
But y'all ain't got nothing to worry about
'cause anybody try to get up in here
I will murder them.
Let me give y'all the tour.
All right, so we got
these vintage windows.
They been here as long as
the building been here.
(beep) get away from the window,
(tires screech)
get away from the window!
Hey, Hey!
You mother-(beep) I see you out there.
You get out that car
and I will murder you.
(tires speed off)
That's what I thought.
Roll on, (beep), roll on.
My nephew Craig.
He a good kid.
He smoke crack though.
Just in case he turns back.
I filed the serial number off there
so if you got to shoot anybody,
just make sure to wipe your
fingerprints off this (beep).
Well, come on, y'all,
I ain't gonna bite you.
Brand new cupboards.
I put the contact paper in myself here
so y'all don't get no germs.
Get down!
Nah, ain't no thing.
I thought Craig was rolling back.
I ain't getting shot by this
mother(beep) twice, damn.
While we down here,
check this out, original hardwood floor
from when the building was built.
Check out this grain, brother.
Ooh, that is craftsmanship.
Anyway, come on.
This paint is all new.
Oh, (beep)
Okay, this happened after I had painted.
Funny story,
we got crack heads in this neighborhood
and one of 'em living right
next door here, right?
And one day he was smoking crack,
just went Looney Toons and
mistook his nine millimeter,
that's a pistol honey,
for the remote control.
But don't worry.
You ain't never gonna see him again.
Ain't nobody ever going to see him again.
Plus, I'm gonna put a
fancy little hook in there
and turn that into a hat wrack.
Let's take a look at this bedroom.
What the (beep)?
- I found this place first!
- Found it?
Man, I own this place.
Can y'all gimme a second?
(Devon and squatter fighting)
You gonna bite me, mother(beep)?
I will cut you with my sword cane.
(fighting continues)
So that's gonna be first
month and last month rent,
one month security deposit,
I'll get the paperwork started.
- Okay, baby, let's hit
this rock real quick.
- [Devon] It's your landlord.
- Hey Devon.
- Hey, how you doing brother?
How you doing?
Yeah, just stopping by.
Just wanted to check up on everything.
- Okay.
Ah-ha!
You in here you little mother(beep)?
Nope.
Closet look good.
Door is strong.
So y'all settling in?
- Yeah, we've been living
here a year and a half.
So we have.
- So how these cupboards
working out for you?
Nobody in here besides your stuff,
which looks good.
- Thank you.
Completely unrelated,
have y'all seen a four foot 11 dude
with a purple beard up in here.
- No, no.
No one's in here probably
because we lock the door.
- Oh, he got the body like a rat.
He can just squeeze through the vents.
- Yeah, so you think somebody's
hiding in my apartment?
- No.
I told you, it's just a social call.
I mean, why would Gerald
be in here anyway.
- Gerald?
There's a man, with a purple beard,
named Gerald in my apartment?
- Hell no.
Why?
Did you see him?
He about four foot nine,
got a purple beard.
- Yeah.
- Hey, baby-
- Ah!
(Kira screams)
Oh, hey baby girl.
You ain't Gerald.
Oh, by the by,
have you seen a four
foot five purple beard?
- Baby.
- Devon, what's going on?
- Okay, you know what I'm
gonna level with y'all,
there is a four foot three (beep)
with a purple beard named Gerald
somewhere in this building.
- Why does he keep getting smaller
every time you mention him?
- Seriously?
Cause I didn't wanna alarm y'all.
He is disturbingly small, really.
He's a good guy.
He smoke rock though.
I mean, he'll do anything
to get money for crack.
Anything.
- Okay.
- I mean anything.
- I get it.
- He will murder you.
- Well, we certainly hope you find him.
- Oh, I'm gonna find him.
Don't worry about that
because I'm gonna look low
and then I'm gonna look high.
- Ah!
(Jordan and Kira scream)
- Gerald, you tiny little bitch!
Sorry for the inconvenience, y'all.
Gerald, when I get my hands on you,
you're gonna be two foot three.
(door slams)
(upbeat music)